i'm really looking forward to the chance
to
answer answer questions that you all
have so intelligence talk multiple
interfaces for equity exploring
opportunities for more equitable and
inclusive learning through multi-mode
technologies
the
game plan for today um
and you know one and just in case
anybody happens to fall asleep a little
bit later on um
wanted to go and show you what the four
takeaways are uh and the first one is
really around intentionality and the
ways that we incorporate ethics and
equity into uh the entire research cycle
so i'm going to touch on that a little
bit uh today
the second one is that multiple
interfaces can make learning
environments more accessible and they
can also promote complex problem solving
so that's one thing would emphasize
multiple analytics can provide
innovative techniques and technologies
that allow you or users to learn about
learning and then fourth multiple
technologies offer a generative space
for people to learn by designing
innovative technologies and experiences
so those are the four big kind of ideas
that i'm gonna be touching on during uh
during today's talk um and i'm gonna try
to give you some examples of each one of
these um and all of these things too are
based on some recent papers that i've
written um and so
if you i i will mention those on on each
of the saw on the slide so you can have
a chance if you want to go take a look
at those papers in more detail
general agenda i'm going to first
introduce quickly introduce uh my lab
tilt and then we're going to get into
talking about some core commitments
and then talking about multiple
interfaces multiple analytics and
multi-modal learning
so
um
you know this work is is done in
conjunction with my lab my lab is called
tilt technological innovation for
inclusive learning and teaching you can
find us at tilt.northwestern.edu
i've got a fun group of phd students
those are the ones that you're seeing
pictured on the left-hand side of the
tee and then
a group of undergraduate students and i
will say not not all of them are even
pictured on here
but an inciting group of undergraduate
students who have really been
been helping to drive this work forward
so the mission of tilt is is
fundamentally to tilt the balance in
favor of those who have been and
continue to be to be marginalized and
with that you know equity is is the
central goal and a part of advancing
equity in in my view
is um also centering those marginalized
identities uh i won't necessarily talk
about them at length now
um or in this talk but for example i
teach a couple of classes at
northwestern um and you know in addition
to teaching sort of intro to hci i also
teach a class called inclusive making
which is really about trying to center
disability within computer science um
and and make sure that we don't treat it
as something that um
it's treated as something that we try to
ignore don't treat something that uh
that is sort of an afterthought we
really inclusive making is really about
trying to center disability um as a
really positive contribution to our
space and really put disability in
conversation with computer science i
have another class that i teach called
sports technology and learning which is
really about centering uh an athletic
identity um within a computer science
context and both of these disability and
athletics tend to be things that i think
sometimes people feel like they have to
leave outside of an academic context and
i'll say more broadly i feel like uh
many people
many people who have relayed to me that
they oftentimes feel like
within some computer science ai kind of
spaces their identity um is not
necessarily welcomed or their identity
uh is not really seen as nasa and so a
lot of the work that i'm trying to do is
really center those identities um and
make sure that we're setting up spaces
where people feel comfortable talking
about those identities and again as we
recognize those identities as bringing
important value to the space
now on top of this idea of centering
equity and centering
identities i really focus on work in
three areas
they're pictured here multimodal
interfaces multi-modal learning and
multimodal analytics and i fundamentally
see these three areas as being
interconnected and so that's that's
probably the other big idea i'm going to
try to leave with you today um and is
that all of these areas multiple
interfaces multiple learning and
multiple analytics can really be used in
service of one another in order to help
advance some of some of the goals that
we want to see on the both the
theoretical side as well as some of the
goals that we want to see on the sort of
the practical and applied side
so what i'm really going to walk through
today then is going to be talking about
some initial core ethical commitments
and then talking about uh projects
within each one of these areas multiple
interfaces multimodal learning and
multiple and analytics
so to start off with core commitments
you know one of the things that started
to happen um with the introduction of
more artificial intelligence the
introduction of more multimodal
technologies
is
increased concern about how these things
might be used to um to honestly to abuse
or to to marginalize a certain
population certain groups um
and so one thing that that i've recently
written on is this idea of what are a
set of core commitments that we should
have as we go about trying to design
with these different types of
multi-modal technologies
in particular ones that that sort of uh
incorporate elements of artificial
intelligence
now i'm not going to go through all of
the
all of the 12 that are listed here but
part of what i'm going to suggest is
that
we want to actually we want to think
about
the use of ethical ethical equitable and
inclusive practices
across the entire research pipeline um
you know
when when we start up a research project
we have to decide who it is we're going
to collect data from what kind of data
we're going to collect how we're going
to collect that data and then
subsequently move into how we analyze
that data and then finally how do we
disseminate that data and what i suggest
is that within each one of these phases
data collection analysis and
dissemination there's some important
things that we have to think about that
have
important implications for
equity inclusion as uh as as well as
ethics um and again i'm just going to
touch on i'm going to touch on one of
them from each one of these one of these
buckets
and sort of encourage you if you want to
look more at those to check out the
paper or you can ask me about them later
on so the three that i'm going to touch
on um is multiple data control
limitations and predictions for
multi-bulk data and lastly uh meaningful
usable feedback
so under multi-modal under data
collection the the first thing i i'm i'm
going to touch on is really this idea
that
participants should have control over
when data is collected about them
i think we we live in a world and i want
to say last year
during the pandemic there is a number of
articles that came out about you know
concerns about when amazon for example
is connecting collecting audio data from
their uh smart speakers for example
and i think there is there is a real
there is an important commitment that
needs to be made around allowing people
to control
when these different types of multimodal
data are or not being uh collected about
them that introduces some some
methodological challenges uh from a
research perspective
but in my view that is something that we
should be designing for um and i think
it's it'll be important for trying to
ensure that we have a more equitable
future um the second one is one that
that uh i'm i'm fairly passionate about
and that's this idea that within data
analysis and inference we really need to
acknowledge the limitations and the
predictions that we get from multi-modal
data
concretely what i mean from that is that
we have to
really avoid this practice of defining
our research participants by their
behavior in a given study so in the
education research space this sometimes
happens where you have students complete
a standardized test and those who scored
high get labeled as high achievers and
those who scored low get labeled as low
achievers
in other instances you might have labels
for kids where you call them engaged
students or disengaged students part of
what i'm suggesting with this and i
think this becomes increasingly
important with with the use of ai and
different kinds of multimodal systems is
that we move away from that practice
and recognize that the behaviors that we
saw from a given participant are highly
contextualized
and to acknowledge the fact that many
times these predictions themselves as
they emerge from ai and sort of machine
learning based systems are biased um and
so that when we go to the step of us
assigning really what what ends up
sometimes being used as um
as a sort of like final label about
somebody we really are in my view doing
a disservice to them and doing a poor
job of representing the contextualized
nature of the data that we that we that
we've collected
as well as the contextualized nature of
the analysis so that's sort of the
second idea is that behavior does not
equal identity and we really need to be
cautious about how we talk about uh
participants and then lastly as it
relates to feedback and dissemination
you know one of the commitments is
really to providing meaningful usable
feedback to participants and this is not
to say that we're not interested in um
growing theory it's to say that i think
there's important ways that we can grow
theory alongside
actually providing useful usable and
useful information to the participants
in the studies
that we end up that we end up having
so then big picture i mean this is that
sort of first takeaway is to kind of be
really intentionable intentional about
the ways that we're thinking about
equity inclusion privacy ethics through
all throughout the various elements of a
of a research project it's not
sufficient to
uh to use an equitable practice in the
data in our data collection
but then subsequently when we do our
data analyses and do
and disseminate our work to kind of
throw those things out the uh window so
that's the sort of first takeaway
all right now with that sort of
groundwork laid we'll actually get into
talking about some of these different
kind of multiple interfaces
so the first one i'm going to talk about
is uh related to a platform that my lab
has been developing called multicraft
and i'm going to suggest that multicraft
kind of demonstrates the ways that ai
can power different sorts of innovations
that make learning environments more
accessible and that promote complex
problem solving
um
quickly by uh by a a
fast reaction how many of you guys
recognize this this picture
can get like a
thumbs up or some sort of
uh zoom reaction if you guys recognize
this picture
i sing a handful i see a thumbs up
any others anybody else recognize yes a
few okay
um so this picture is from a popular
uh virtual reality game called minecraft
um and the multi-craft project really
came about because i was i was visiting
a middle school classroom where at the
end of the unit when students have
finished their their projects
and these projects can be involving
things like photoshop or using adobe
illustrator or 3d printing
when students finish up their projects
the teacher allows for them to spend
some time designing and building in in
minecraft in this specific class though
there was a a young eighth grade
young black eighth grade boy who had
cerebral palsy uh which really inhibited
him from being able to uh simultaneously
simultaneously use a keyboard and mouse
um and for those you guys who know about
minecraft you know one of the ways that
people canonically use the game is to
put one hand on the mouse to be able to
uh control where you're looking
um as well as to
control mining and building so either
breaking blocks or like putting blocks
down or opening doors and your other
hand on the keyboard uh and using the
the
wasd
um
uh buttons to actually be able to
navigate around around this virtual
world
so for this specific student because he
had cerebral palsy he was not able to
control the keyboard enough at the same
time and that effectively uh kept him
from being able to play the game
effectively kept him from being able to
participate along with his peers in this
experience um and for me that was very
frustrating frustrating to see
um and that's really one of the things
that motivated us trying to develop this
multi-craft platform where multicraft is
this uh
ultimately it's a it's a plug-in uh a
minecraft um it's a minecraft server
uh that we that we host
that allows for people to interact with
the with the game using speech-based
input using eye tracking they can still
use a keyboard and mouse if they want to
though we have changed we have
introduced some shorthand text input so
that they don't have to type out full
commands they can interact with the game
using wooden blocks
using eeg and we've recently been
working on adding some uh
computer vision based uh gesture
recognition
so the idea is really that we want to
provide as many different modalities as
possible for participants to be able to
participate uh within this minecraft
experience and and as part of that it's
not just that we want to replace the
keyboard and mouse we really are trying
to get towards equitable participation
so for us it wasn't sufficient to just
replace um
the mouse for example with an eye
tracker or to have a
a
virtual keyboard show up on the screen
and the student to use for the student
use eye gaze to control it we really
wanted to make sure that the play was
going to be equitable so we also
embedded a number of sort of commands
that can even speed up speed up the play
i'm going to show you in the next few
slides
a handful of examples of how we're using
this multi-bulk of data
but just wanted to give you a quick
picture of the architecture uh one of
the other a few of the things that we've
been adding in recently uh is that we
previously had a lot of these a lot of
the multicraft clients actually reside
within like a python program we recently
switched that over so that it is it's a
it's primarily browser-based and so
we're trying to think of as many ways as
possible to make these things accessible
um we've also switched out our previous
use of the tobii 4ci tracker and can now
do eye tracking using just a a webcam so
the goal is is really to try to provide
an experience once again students are
able to use whichever of these
technologies they have
access to
and to really allow them to find new
ways to play the game
so
um here's just an example of of a video
from where
somebody provided verbal instructions to
the game and the sort of structure was
built
instantaneously so this is an example of
how we're thinking more about equitable
play and so instead of just having a
verbal instruction that says put a block
down put a block down put a block down
move over put a block down we actually
allow for the students to make a verbal
command that will actually create this
entire structure um at all at once
uh the next slide here is showing an
example of a sort of eye tracking
overlay
when the students are actually playing
the game they don't see that little
bubble in the middle of the screen
that's something we can we can easily
turn on and off but in this case the
student is able to use their eyes to be
able to
look around and actually control where
their avatar is looking
and within some of our commands too we
actually we do
allow multiple diffusion which means if
i'm looking at at a certain location and
i say make a five by seven by eight
structure here it will actually build
that structure where i am i'm looking uh
so we are really trying to think about
bringing together these different kinds
of multimodal commands
the other pieces that we that we've
incorporated um one of the ones i'm
really excited about is the ability to
build using wooden blocks um or really
build in the physical world so on the
right hand side you're seeing uh one of
the early one of the prototypes of a
platform called tangie craft
which was a at that time it was a set of
laser-cut blocks that we created with
fiducial markers on them as well as uh
we had created a sort of haptic feedback
device that was really geared towards
allowing someone
who was blind or visually impaired to be
able to play the minecraft play play
minecraft um on the left hand side
you're seeing a somewhat updated version
where instead of having to have blocks
that have specific specific fiducial
markers on them we can just use any sort
of generic blocks
and use that as a way for people to
design and build with uh now on the next
slide i'm actually gonna have a quick
video of a slightly more recent version
of this on the right you're gonna see
someone adding in blocks
and then on the left-hand side you'll
see those blocks showing up in the game
in real time
so they're going to add two more and
those two other blocks are going to show
up in front of it
and so this is kind of an example of the
the user experience you want to be able
to have and actually what we currently
do have
uh where
as as the participant is adding and
removing blocks
and again these blocks in the physical
world
the game is is
nearly in real time making updates um to
actually reflect that
uh and you know this this as we've
explored it has important implications
and and provides new ways of engaging
that enhance accessibility but there's
also some important ways that this
provides for different types of
engagement so i don't know how many guys
have ever watched a group of middle
school students try to play minecraft
together uh where they're all using the
same computer
but i can i can tell you right now it
typically doesn't work uh that many
times the students are sort of fighting
over that keyboard and mouse
to kind of be in control
if instead we allow for participants to
use physical blocks it makes it much
easier for them to be able to engage in
collaborative building even though they
might all might all be connected to uh
just one single user within minecraft
and that's some of the things that we're
that we're really trying to advocate for
is to
not just again replace the keyboard and
mouse replace the input modality but
also try to promote different ways of
engaging and even try to set up a
scenario for example where
perhaps it's a young kid who does not
feel comfortable using
using any of the other input modalities
whether it be keyboard and mouse or
using speech
that they can actually
build with these physical wooden blocks
or it can actually be a an adult and a
child coming together to collaboratively
play in the spirit experience together
um so one of the neat things with this
too though is that
alongside using the multimodal input the
multiple data for people to
control the interface there's also ways
that they can actually use we can use
the multimodal data to
study what they're doing and
this has been providing us an important
window into thinking about spatial
reasoning in particular in particular
and so these green dots you're seeing on
the screen are sort of an eye-tracking
overlay of the information that this the
participants were sort of visually and
engaging with um that is helping us
see the ways that students are
practicing uh traditional spatial
reasoning practices within minecraft as
well as helping us see some kind of
honestly new kinds of spatial reasoning
practices that we no we would not
necessarily see within the the physical
world
um so this you know this will start to
bring me to the next point i'll quickly
say my multi-craft as a platform is
really motivated by goals of
accessibility
but we've also really been using it as a
way to engage students in computational
thinking and spatial reasoning and help
us see that competition in spatial
reasoning
so big picture multiple input opens up
new possibilities for inclusive and
equitable learning while also
facilitating practices uh facilitating
practice of complex skills like spatial
reasoning like computational thinking
um but they at the same time these
multiple interfaces can be a really cool
way to go about trying to study and
support learning
and so to give you an example of this
we're going to now turn to multi-modal
analytics where i kind of suggest that
ai can provide innovative technologies
and techniques that allow you or users
to learn about their learning
so this is part of a paper
connected paper called designing
analytics for collaboration literacy and
student empowerment uh that came out
earlier this year
so the sort of
guiding question around this this
project was what does good collaboration
look like um and you know admittedly
researchers have been studying
collaboration for a long time right and
uh research have even come up with these
sort of
complicated maps of okay here seemed
here seem to be a number of different
themes that people look at related to
collaboration and now we can break those
themes down into these different
categories
um and then those categories can be
subsequently sort of grouped into two
different domains and all this
information is is actually really really
informative for helping researchers in
particular think about
collaboration but one of my big
interests is what does this mean for
students how is it that students think
about collaboration and how do we go
about representing collaboration um and
collaboration information to students uh
specifically with this goal of helping
them develop collaboration literacy
which is i sort of describe as their
ability to
know how to collaborate but also to know
how to read a given collaborative
situation and to know how to respond
and so that's sort of the guiding
guiding question for this current
project i'm going to talk to right now
is called blink how do students think
about collaboration so
to do this
we're going to oh and so as part of this
as part of this study we we ran a survey
a couple years ago where we got input
from undergraduate and graduate students
about how they collaborate what good
collaboration looks like what bad
collaboration looks like how they would
what kind of things they would tell
someone else about collaboration
and that gave us this sort of category
the set of categories um and i won't go
into the detail about all these
categories but what they started to help
us do was to inform the ways that
students seem to be thinking about
collaboration and that's important
because what we were what we're working
on and what we've been developing is an
interface um and really a data analytics
dashboard that is there to try to
support student uh real-time as well as
post-talk uh collaborative sessions so
we're going to try this
um
if you guys can go to
tilt dash blink.com
it shows up on my screen here
tilt dash
blink.com i'm gonna sign in
and we'll see if uh if this is going to
work
so
what i'm doing is i'm creating a
discussion
uh rather i'm setting up to create a
discussion when i do this i can create a
custom work keyword list these would be
words that the um
that the tool will pay attention to
i'll press next and i'm going to start
my discussion
now if you all like i said if you went
to tilt-blink.com
you'll have this option to join
discussion so if you click on join
discussion
and then type in your name it doesn't
really have to be a real name you can
choose a fake name so i'll even put in
none
and then we're going to put this code
qm43
in here
qm43 qm43
i'm gonna say join discussion
so
now what we've done is
i have connected you guys are basically
all connecting to this platform
and you guys are now participants
in this sort of full class discussion
the idea behind the blink platform is
multi-fold one is this idea that
what happens in a classroom what
happened typically happens in a
classroom that has a large number of
users in it
is that we typically engage in lecturing
and part reason why we engage in
lecturing is because it's hard to manage
a classroom that's having a lot of small
group discussion
uh and so one of the things we we
thought was okay what happens if we
actually set up these audio data
collection devices inside the classroom
space so that if an instructor wants to
click in and see what's happening within
a given group um and actually my guess
is they're not going gonna be much audio
because i'm doing most of the talking
right now
um
but if an instructor wants to come in
and see what's happening within a given
group they can click into this display
and they'll see what kind of verbal uh
information is being um has been
captured so it should work if i go into
none
let's see if it's gotten any audio
so when i clicked into none this was the
one that i was using
um you'll see there's a transcript of
the words that i was saying
and so this is one of the things that
platform provides it'll uh do real-time
speech recognition and then
provide that information for the user to
be able to uh to look at um within this
two
it does something oh i didn't want to go
back here yet
it will provide me with a sort of uh
timeline of um when it detects text when
it is or when it's detecting a
discussion it'll identify when it
detects a question so like what's the
day today
um and also annotate silence down here
we have a
and this is a representation we're still
working on with this specific with um
this kind of microphone um but we also
have it set up with a specialized
microphone array that will give you a
sort of a heat map or more so a
visualization of how much verbal
contribution is coming from different
portions of a small group
down below you're seeing like a keyword
detection so maybe this is a chemistry
class and you're looking you want to
keep track of discussions related to i
don't know covalent bonds or ions or
protons um or i don't know phenol
alanine or something you can customize a
set of keywords that you want to be able
to sort of quickly go in and identify
and then you also have these discussion
features so this is using um
this is using sort of a sentiment
classifier to look at the emotional tone
analytic thinking or clout of different
utterances
so when we go in here i think i asked a
question uh
something didn't want to go back here
yet i'm not even sure that that i said
that but oh well um
some of the other representations that
you get with this tool one you can click
into a given keyword and it'll take you
to the transcripts you can actually see
a full transcript of what was said the
idea here is that this is something that
is hopefully useful to a group who's
engaging in a group discussion in that
moment to kind of say okay what were we
talking about previously in our in this
in this discussion um and you can sort
of highlight where those keywords came
about
the other neat view with this is
looking at the graph
so if i go into this graph i can
actually see all of the group
discussions
at the same time now with as many people
that have signed in as there have been
it's going to be a lot
but what you'll see is that i can sort
of quickly look at a given person i can
click on a certain device um and see you
know here were the questions that arose
from there from the microphone and then
here just more generally um sort of an
overview of the relative contributions
uh from each each of the groups so this
is just this is an example of a of a
live platform that we've been working on
um
that
that is really gay aimed towards trying
to represent many of those concepts that
i was just showing you guys
uh many of these ideas
of being able to represent climate
communication compatibility conflict
context contribution and the sort of
constructive category as embedded within
a server collaboration analytics tool
that we see as trying to provide
real-time support for students as well
as supporting uh research
and again the goal being that these kind
of tools can support more inclusive and
more active kind of classroom
experiences so i won't get into
sort of details with all this i will
quickly say though the idea of being
able to do this from your smartphone um
was something that came up as part of
the research because one thing that we
we observed especially in higher
education a lot of the collaboration
that happens happens outside of the
classroom space so we wanted to make
sure that we had a tool that students
could essentially use on their time
outside of the classroom that is going
to record this information for them and
then subsequently be there for for their
teams to be able to use in the moment or
for them to go back and look at later on
um but big picture i kind of see this
idea of ai and multiple analytics can
really help us think about how we learn
to collaborate and ultimately want to
suggest that for certain constructs and
even certain practices like
collaboration we really might want to
have more of these computational tools
that are using multimodal data
as i think those can help us help
support and characterize how
collaboration is being developed so in
the case of learning collaboration you
know
instructors have very little window into
what a collaboration looked like um in
your in your dorm room in your your
residence
but if you're able to have a sort of
data collection tool like this that has
some various analytics components in it
um that could potentially inform or
improve and even offer some support for
students as they're trying to trying to
collaborate um and more importantly
uh it can also go alongside some some
pedagogical approaches that an
instructor might take um in trying to
help people reflect on how they were how
they were collaborating
all right
the last piece um is you know we were
just looking at collaboration as a
context we looked at sort of multi-modal
uh we looked at minecraft as a context
um i also get really excited about the
ways that we can use multimodal
technology as a way to engage people in
learning through designing those
multi-modal technologies so
this work is is uh related to a project
that called sports sense
it was previously called data in motion
you can you can check out some of the
stuff on this um at tilted northwestern
edu slash projects
sports analytics
and the big picture behind behind sports
sense is really trying to
um again to center
identities related to athletics in an
academic context
and to say that there's important ways
that athletics can be used to as a space
to learn about artificial intelligence
and there's important ways that
artificial intelligence and multiple
technologies can be used to improve
athletic performance
at the professional level i think people
see a lot more of this
but as sort of at the youth level i
think it ends up being a lot more opaque
and people really start to think about
these two areas as separate silos and
not seeing the opportunities that exist
that can exist between them
um so this work is is actually it's work
that uh do in collaboration and with in
partnership with several different
organizations
so evanson skokie school district we
work with with
physical education and coding or
computer science teachers to incorporate
some activities and design some
activities that that have relevance and
connection between pe class and coding
class we're working with the chicago
parks district and working with many of
their after-school educators to embed
some of these experiences as part of the
after school space work with the
evanston public library
we're working with a
a basketball team in
puerto rico
so vocational
and then we're also working with a
number of other organizations
within the within chicagoland one of
these the block is a youth boxing club
um and then we've been working with the
evanston township high school but this
is just to say that
we're seeing a lot of spaces where we
can actually engage in this kind of work
both informal and
and formal
um big picture and there's there's
actually a lot of stuff i can talk about
with sports since what we've ended up
developing so far
is a curriculum that we came up with
primarily for the pandemic
that goes through six different weeks or
sort of like six different modules the
first one is this idea of the power of
sensors and we ended up developing this
module because kids seem to have a hard
time thinking about sensors and they had
some concerns about you know what is a
sensor and so we we
now we sort of expose them to the idea
of sensors
through spider-man into the spider-verse
and start to help them think about
the types of digital sensors that many
of us use or that embed inside many
technologies that we have
many of those things are actually
modeled after human senses and so we
really try to ground the idea of sensors
in our human senses
we then move on to have the students
start to explore some low-cost wearables
so the micro bit is one of these one of
those wearables that we have them we
have them used and one of the neat
things you have to do with the micro bit
is actually replicate some existing um
at sometimes expensive wearable
technology using these sensors on the
micro bed and this ends up being like a
powerful experience for them um because
many of them kind of look at this like
wow i had like i had no idea i was
actually able to create something like
this um and the really neat thing is
that these these micro bits since
they've there's a programming in the
programming language for them is block
based uh and so it's something that many
of the youth feel comfortable doing
next step is we have a module called
take off that silly watch
where we kind of say all right let's put
the wearables aside and let's see what
we can do with computer vision
and so we actually have them replicate
again another commercial application
that's part of this home court
basketball app we have them replicate
that in the scratch programming
environments
using some of the built-in computer
vision capabilities
and once again it's not one of those
things that students do and they kind of
look back in disbelief of their that
they were actually able to create
something like that
uh we didn't have a couple we have a
couple of sessions where we talk about
limitations of sensors and wearables uh
so we actually encourage them to try to
hack some of the technologies that we've
been using
and really want to say hack or really
just try to trick them so how do you
trip and trick a step counter how do you
trick a computer vision system that
might be counting how many push-ups
you're doing
and then we also talk about some of the
more societal level challenges um
societal level problems that arise when
using uh facial recognition technology
for example um and the ways that that
that sometimes those technologies are
used and they violate people's privacy
and other times we also see them used to
uh to criminalize people from particular
people of color
um we also take them through a design
thinking process
um and you know we have them complete a
number of different design activities
one of the sort of design activities you
have to do is
create a sort of design comic
so you know think about a specific
technology that they that they might
want to make and kind of put together a
little comic around it and then we also
highlight um many designers of color so
on the right hand side you're seeing
stephanie lampkin
stephanie
was a stanford alum
in
i want to say electrical engineering
mechanical engineering or
cs i sadly don't remember um but
stephanie was uh was a contemporary of
mine and uh now runs uh is now ceo of a
company there in the bay area
um
and so what we do in this in this space
we have a various types of programs one
of them is we'll do these pop-up
sessions where we'll actually have
students go through this process of like
drawing out their different design ideas
and so here's just some pictures of some
designs that students have created
on the left-hand side you're seeing a
dancing robot that's supposed to teach
someone how to dance um in the middle
you're seeing a golf ball with sensors
inside of it that lets you know how hard
you hit it uh and then on the right hand
side you're seeing the sort of robot
coach
the neat thing is is
to see the the ways that students have
some pretty powerful ideas and once they
get access to the tools to start to
create and build out those ideas they
become extremely empowered they become
they begin to see more of their agency
and so
really the big idea here then oh i'll
get the amendments that
the big idea is that really engaging
people in embodied experiences where
they design ai powered multi-modal
innovations can be a general approach
for learning i almost forgot to mention
you know one of the things that we we've
started to see with these programs is
that we can even in the course of a
quick week i see students drastically
shift in their perceptions of the
connection between technology and sports
so within this this group of students i
think is from a summer program
when the students started the program
most of them did not see much of a
connection between
technology and improving in sports and
after just you know short five days uh
students started to actually see that as
a
as as an actual opportunity and see uh
connections between technology and uh
and improving in sports
um and this actually this work is part
of what motivated us to
start working with teachers uh in
particular pe teachers and coding
teachers at the elementary school level
and so we've been co-developing uh some
some activities that again that are
built around those six modules that i
shared earlier
um okay so to kind of wrap things up
hopefully i've touched on each of these
these four takeaways um
really the idea of being intentional
across the entire research life cycle
the idea of multiple interfaces being a
way to create learning environments that
are more accessible and that at the same
time can promote different types of
complex reasoning complex practices
uh then multiple analytics can bring
innovative techniques and technologies
for studying learning and then that
lastly that
engaging people in the design of
multimodal technologies that you all
that are oftentimes leveraging ai can be
a really another another important way
to um to promote learning
um and now to get back to this this
thing around you know equity and
identities one of the things that i've
really been interested in is how do we
how do we go about designing new kind of
learning experiences
um and that's part of the way i kind of
come into this work is how do we come up
with these new ways of of creating these
learning experiences
but that also has to be coupled with
ways for how to assess and support uh
and so hopefully from there you kind of
see some of the connections between
these three areas between multiple
learning developing multiple interfaces
so that those multi-modal learning
experiences are accessible um and that
they are engaging and that they're
allowing people to do things that might
otherwise seem infeasible for them and
then alongside that to see the ways that
the multiple analytics
can build off of those multiple
interfaces
to support the multiple learning
experiences as well as um to to really
sort of drive the the the multiple
interfaces uh so with that i will
conclude and looks like we should
hopefully have about 15 minutes or so
for questions thank you
evaluating collaborative teams like for
example i don't know if you're if you've
used the catney tool before or other
ones like it but basically that rely on
uh basically student team self reporting
uh you know basically their
collaborative
different measures across collaboration
verse uh you know which i think have
been shown to be biased right that will
basically people that have been
traditionally you know minoritized tend
to
be you know fair works on self-reported
uh measures and the perception
of team members is skewed by these
biases that people have so there's
obviously problems with self-report at
the same time there's sort of issues
that you kind of brought up in maybe the
first uh
part of your work that you mentioned in
terms of sort of uh the aspects of
surveillance and
what are the sort of ethics and and how
people are you know aware of or
concerned with
um you know basically having these
collaborative meetings recorded and then
knowing that that's going to affect
their their grade and yeah
technologies and what i think about the
the analytics as i really think about
them as a compliment
um
and part of like a full mix i was in a
talk yesterday
um
where there's discussion around the fact
that
it's not that we want to it's not that
we want to avoid conflict or not avoid
conflict it's not that we it's not that
when
when you get differing signals from
different modalities whether that uh is
coming from self reports whether it
comes from audio data or video data it's
not that we're trying to uh necessarily
fight to see which one of those is the
best it's it's that we're trying to do
what we can to sorry about the sneeze
oh wait no maybe not um do we can to try
to get a holistic picture and kind of
a conversation um
thing i'm going to say about the blink
platform is that none of what we try to
do is to be prescriptive so at no point
do we try to say you're not talking
enough at no point there's no point
where we try to say um you need to to
listen more
and a lot of that too has to do with the
specific context and that typically
we only have a very limited window into
that context
um and this is also something that
students raise concerns about when when
they think about analytic analytic tech
uh collaboration analytics is that
there's so often so much context that
the
the concern is that the predictions that
they get the prescriptions that they get
are not going to do a good job of
reflecting that uh reflecting that that
context um and so that's one of the ways
that we try to approach this for now is
we're going to service information and
we really want that information to be
connected to
some um
some structure that is actually designed
to help people learn about collaboration
and this is probably a whole nother rant
that i could go on
but i'll spare you but generally i don't
feel like we actually teach people to
collaborate we just kind of say
okay go and work together we don't
provide much scaffolding around the
collaborative experience such that
people are actually learning to
collaborate and so one of the goals of
this kind of tool is for it to be
connected to
a more structured or a more formalized
learning experience related to
collaboration that would likely include
some of those self-reports and actually
thinking about having those self-reports
alongside the audio data or alongside
the transcript data
from that that given collaborative
session
thanks do your hand up go ahead
yeah um thank you so much for your talk
um i think the work you do is really
amazing
um i think maybe my question is um i
have two questions one of the questions
um might be related to strong's question
um which is about like how how you deal
with the kind of discordance or like uh
discrepancy like between different
measures but in multimodal like data
analysis
um yeah like for instance like um
i i i don't think you kind of like it
go uh deep into this issue like for
instance like when we analyze student um
um behavior like from verbal nonverbal
the gesture gaze um and their physic
physical um
engagements uh in the case of emotion
for instance you have facial uh movement
um you know speech and and the verbal
content um but then like in the data
analysis you want to decide on a measure
or you either integrate them or or or
choose one like to kind of um
analyze the data but um in this case of
like uh in motion um for instance um um
measure uh uh oftentimes there's full
concordance amongst those measures i
wonder like how you deal with that i'm
sorry i kind of went into no no
so um
yeah i have another question um okay let
me i'll show you the first one i'll
answer the first one first and that is
that um when you actually one of the
commitments that we talk about
is that
uh when analyzed multi-modal data in
particular
i think it's important to engage the
participants
in that inference process
that
there needs to be some feedback from the
participants on like hey
this is what i'm seeing from the data
walk me through it let me please like
help me help me understand
like what you were feeling within that
moment now it's not to say that that
approach is going to be perfect because
people don't always understand what
they're experiencing people always don't
understand even like what their
subconscious might be expressing that i
get into this some because i um some of
the studies i have they'll use uh i'll
use skin conductance or electrodermal
activity um or using something like eeg
and the reality is that people don't
always know quite what they're feeling
but
in my view i think part of our
responsibility in using some of this
multiple data is to also take some of it
back to the participants and kind of say
look here's what we're seeing from this
data like can you provide some
qualitative description or can you
provide some insights
to help us as we think about and
interpret this data
so like mixed methods kind of approach
to
uh yeah no thank you so much um
the other question i have um is about
like bias reduction
um like i i i really like um this vision
you had i think the class you teach
about inclusive making i wonder like how
having access to the multimodal um
kind of data of of students like moment
by moment learning process can
potentially address this labeling issue
like labeling students uh with
using like standard uh standardized uh
tests
um
and like how how and how how do you
assess students performance and growth
experience using the new paradigm
thank you so i did i i maybe have time
for this story i'll see you at 1 55. um
so
this actually this this kind of came
about in a
a middle or high school class that i was
leading um at stanford so we had
students coming to our maker lab for two
months out of the year there's one
student in a class that when i watched
him i thought he was just always goofing
off like he was always telling jokes he
was always seemed like he was a
troublemaker um when i actually went
back and watched the video of that class
i started to see that in one day in
particular i see someone come from clear
the other side of the room to come ask
him a question and then he helps that
person with that question i see someone
else come from a different corner of the
room and come and ask him that that
question and
from what i saw in the moment
when i was in the class i thought he was
a class clown and he did do some things
that that sort of
would uh suggest that but at the same
time i was missing out on the fact that
his peers had started to recognize him
as an expert in a certain area and so i
think the multimodal data in that case
if i if i had had like indoor location
tracking setup
i probably could have seen some of those
things emer i could have probably seen
some of those activities um start to
start to to to show up
now having said that i do have some
concerns about just putting a bunch of
these technologies in all kinds of
learning spaces um for the issues of
privacy for the issues of ethics that i
mentioned earlier on um and so generally
actually think about you know what is
the minimum amount of technology that we
can provide while still providing
tangible benefit or while still helping
us to interrogate the kind of questions
we want to get at and so
many times what we'll do is we'll
actually use the full suite of
technologies in more of a laboratory
context so we can start to understand a
given phenomena or understand a given
practice and then take
take the insights from that and apply it
to the learning space with uh with fewer
of those technologies
thank you so much
uh looks like
see a hand
hey there yeah thank you so much for
this talk um this work is really vital
and exciting to me um i'm curious to
hear more about your research
decisions in the design sessions that
you run and in particular you said once
students have access to tools to create
their designs they begin to see their
agency um i'm currently running a
participatory design and development
project with sixth grade girls and
non-binary youth as well i'm trying to
think how much scaffolding or support do
you give in bringing student designs to
life the more you give the more excited
they are to see like wow we do these
amazing things but you know maybe a
little less student agency than in that
whole process it feels a little less
participatory
so yeah yeah i mean that one that's
really really it's hard to do and i feel
like it varies by student um in that for
some students um
some students they get such as this big
idea and then they get overwhelmed with
that with that that that big idea uh and
i mean adults we do this too but some of
it has to do with trying to help help um
help kind of manage that scope or even
help be able to piece things down into
into like a smaller set of things that
they can uh that they can start to
accomplish um
so what are the kind of things that we
in that we end up doing um
one is we do a lot of we do a lot of
things with with uh well we'll actually
bring prototypes that we've created
um and sometimes we bring those
prototypes that we've created so that
students can start to see
um start to see what some of those
possibilities are
um other times you know it's it's i feel
like it's it is much more
kind of student-led and sometimes it
takes it down a bad path sometimes um
sometimes sometimes not but i think we
end up providing a mix of here is very
open-ended versus here is like fully
scripted of here's how you would
actually create this thing to
here is the actual thing like
test it use it play with it
but there's not the expectation that
they will actually have to go through
and um and create all of those things so
i don't i don't know that there's like a
a magic i don't know that there's a
single solution or a single sort of
answer for
um
for it i think a lot of it is to design
for a lot of possibilities designed for
for the student who does just want to
sit down and do it by themselves and
they will hammer it out for hours
designed for have a design available for
the student who
wants to get that scaffolding um and
like it would be excited to just follow
those instructions and get to get that
thing working and then design for the
student who
you know uh roadblock comes up they're
gonna kind of throw up their hands and
give it up because i think i think
there's important pieces along all of
those paths and
when we think about the timelines we
oftentimes think about like something
being successful if the student finishes
it within like a week or within two
weeks but we don't really know the full
extent of the impact of some of these
experiences because it could be three
years from now it could be two months
from now where a student um finally
starts to make those those connections
so also i think
temper our expectations for what success
looks like uh within within that space
okay i've seen
i think you're really interesting talk
uh
um so i'm curious to go back to the
point you made right at the beginning
about giving users control of data you
mentioned it comes with methodological
challenges
so i was wondering if you could
elaborate a little bit on what those
challenges are and how you deal with
them
and maybe how you're thinking about that
in the context of link especially
yes the methodological challenges
you know we oftentimes
in research
when we just go and collect data the
assumption is that we're getting a
representative sample
of student engagement a representative
sample
of
of that interaction
and when we instead
are getting
choice snippets
of interactions choice snippets the
parts that people want us to hear um
that starts to mess with some of the
ways that we oftentimes talk about
talk about the findings
um and so in in one sense uh it might
push against concerns around uh
around the generalizability of these
things and
you know i think i think for me it
doesn't create as much of a problem
because in many instances what i'm
looking for is just instances of
students demonstrating some competency
or demonstrating some interest or
demonstrating something
but from the much more
i mean i i they would probably say much
more rigorous um more of like
randomized controlled trial kind of
level um they want to see
all the students data all for the entire
time to actually be able to run that
comparison and so i think because of
that we have to think about
what are the kinds of methodologies or
what are the kind of analyses that we
would use um that would align with this
idea of students to be able to determine
when the data is collected about them
and when it's not and at the same time
that introduces a challenge of
being able to like
resolutely provide
appropriate support for the learners
so if it is just those choice moments
that they're recording
we might be missing out on either
important meaningful contributions that
they're making or some of the challenges
that might start to arise within that
within that space um so those are like
those are some of the
some of the tensions that we that i feel
like we start to think about um and one
of the other ones that i'll quickly
mention is that within the blink
platform we do not record audio there's
no
like we can record the audio we can
store the audio on our servers but we
don't
we run it through a speech recognition
and then we just save the transcript
that introduces a problem too
because one we do that because we want
to maintain people's privacy
but there's also this challenge of you
now lose the context
you you you do not have a record to go
back to to say okay this is really what
the person said
um instead you're now relying on
what was the output of the speech
recognition system when
that actually might do harm
um in terms of how that student is being
represented or either how that group is
being represented so that ended up being
one of these other tensions too
um around sort of like adopting some of
these commitments adopting some of these
practices um and how those things can
still subsequently sort of have um some
have some introduce some challenges
so much marcelo for the wonderful talk
um
let's all give marcelo a virtual round
of applause
[Applause]
you